so at Lollapalooza there was a security  worker she wanted to go home early guess  what she did she set fire to the concert  did she call for a bomb threat she sent  a fake text mass shooting we have 150  targets okay wait can I can I can I say  something can we see what you saw show  first and then I want to say what I want  to say that's her now  okay that was gonna be my next guest me  too me too  dude I didn't want to say it I love my  people I love my people I love you you  tried but you could you could have done  better I forgive you but I was like she  black  wait so they're they're holding her yeah  50 000 bail do you think she's like can  I get out early  it goes to show that black people still  don't do mass shootings we just we fake  them you call them in you're like the  white dude is coming up here now he's  gonna get your [ __ ] y'all  better run